in a successful tv series it's important
to have compelling main characters that
make the viewers want to tune in for
every episode but those winning leads
shouldn't get all the credit for a
show's success
the supporting players and often the
antagonists are vital to filling out the
world of the show
take for example the character of yasmin
from the netflix series cobra kai
her penchant for being nasty to her
classmates might not have you rooting
for her
but when the character returned to the
halls of west valley high after not
appearing in season 2
there's a good chance you realize how
vital she is to the ecosystem of the
show
and that is a testament to the
performance of the actor who plays her
annalisa cochran you may also be
thinking that she looks kind of familiar
cobra kai is far from cochrane's first
on-screen performance
from tv guest spots to starring roles
and films cochrane already has an
impressive list of credits to her name
here are a few of the tv series and
movies where you may have seen cobra
kai's resident mean girl
consider me more of a an admirer from
afar oh my god
these losers as with many actors getting
their start in the business
cochran's career began with a string of
short films and guest star appearances
on tv shows
before her recurring role on cobra kai
you may have spotted her on episodes of
modern family
major crimes and it's always sunny in
philadelphia
this is super weird all right this is
our thing
she parlayed that work into a
multi-episode arc on the long-running
daytime soap opera the young and the
restless in 2017
and also had a one-episode role on days
of our lives around the same time
however for her next recurring part she
moved away from soaps and into the world
of edgy contemporary reboots
after finishing up her run on the young
and the restless cochran joined the cast
of the paramount network reboot of 80s
teen movie satire heathers
she played shelby on the short-lived
series a cheerleader who is barely on
the periphery of being acknowledged by
the popular clique at westerberg high
school
although her character faces a
considerable amount of bullying on the
series
according to cochran her experience
filming the show couldn't be more
different speaking with entertainment
website close-up culture
cochrane talked about the experience of
shooting heathers saying
every show that i've been on has been a
remarkable experience
but this one in particular stands out
not only did it have me amazed at every
episode every costume every crazy detail
but it gave me a community of
like-minded people who i call some of my
best friends today
the series itself ended up being a bit
of a debacle overall
being met with controversy a delayed
rollout and poor critical reception
but it sounds like it was a rewarding
experience for cochran nonetheless
see he is in the girls bathroom it's
heather
does it say heather on your birth
certificate does it say a weasel on
yours
other than popping up on soaps and high
school set tv dramas
cochrane has also done a lot of work in
the world of horror and sci-fi
she starred in the 2019 film apparition
as skyler
a woman whose friend invents an app that
is able to give the living direct
communication with death
they test it out at an abandoned former
boys school where a horrible tragedy
happened
and to nobody's surprise but their own
that ends up being a really big mistake
she also co-starred in the ensemble film
confessional where she plays raquel
one of several college students who
receive a mysterious request to come to
a sound booth on campus
once there they are grilled about their
connection to the mysterious deaths of
some of their fellow students
on the tv and streaming side cochran
nabbed parts on two recent horror and
sci-fi anthology series
on hulu's into the dark she appears in
the segment titled pure
the eerie supernatural thriller combines
the nightmarish
subculture of virginity pledges and
purity balls with some good
old-fashioned supernatural possession
although the jordan peel-produced weird
city is more sci-fi than horror
it also uses social issues to draw its
viewers into a sense of unease
the episode go to college is about a
young woman from a lower social class
who finds herself at a university with
some exceptionally suspicious rich kids
one of whom is played by cochran amazing
you are hilarious i already feel like
we're besties
playing the mean girl may not always win
you the most love from fans
but as annalisa cochran proves doing it
well can be a work of art
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]